seit der pandemie riskieren wir
tagtäglich unsere gesundheit und die
unser angehörigen wir mussten mit
unzureichender schutzausrüstung am
patientenbett arbeiten masken tragen die
wieder aufbereitet wurden die dafür über
gar nichts zugelassen sind infiziert zur
arbeit gehen und dann sagt man uns auf
einmal wenn ihr morgen nicht geimpft und
eine gefahr für die patienten darstellt
dann seid ihr schon willkommen das ist
für mich eine unglaubliche doppelmoral
und ja herr söder war einer der ersten
der diese endlich gefordert hat jetzt
sieht dann sind wieder zurück und das
ist wie in der ganzen pandemie es werden
immer zwei schritte vor dem ersten
gemacht man bringt debatten ins spiel
die dann nicht durchdacht sind und dann
wieder zurückgenommen werden